[Music]
this week i was diagnosed with stage
four pancreatic cancer
now normally the prognosis for this is
not very encouraging
but i'm gonna fight this it was in march
of 2019 when the beloved game show host
went public with his heartbreaking
battle
stage four meant that the cancer had
spread to other parts of his body
and with the love and support of my
family and friends
and with the help of your prayers also
i plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease
right after making his devastating
announcement alex took on cancer
head on i have good days and
a few days after chemo that
kind of lay me low for a little bit but
overall i'm improving
my numbers are improving and i'm very
positive about
the outcome he continued to tape
episodes of jeopardy
while having chemo one side effect
caught losing his hair
the challenge for jeopardy viewers is
right now
is to figure out is that alex's real
hair
or is that a full hairpiece
you're looking right now this is not the
real me
just two months after revealing his
cancer battle alex won his sixth emmy
alex trevor i'm aware that there must be
a fair amount of sympathy
that went into the voting for this but
to tell you the truth
i don't care i i've got the award
and i enjoy having this award
for a while it seemed alex was beating
the odds often pushing through pain
he announced that his tumors were
shrinking and that he had finished chemo
before starting jeopardy's 36th season
he celebrated his 79th birthday on the
set
and did push-ups i'm on the mend and
that's all i
over the years e.t spent a lot of time
with the canadian-born icon
always humble after he was inducted into
the nab broadcasting hall of fame
he was grateful for his long career i've
been a broadcaster for 56 years
and this is quite an honor and
i guess it's fitting that it comes at
this point in my career
near the end alex trebek
hosting jeopardy since 1984 e.t visited
the set before it even hit the air it's
a cerebral thing americans like to
compete
and they want to know that i liken it to
the television commercial that's on the
air right now
they want to make money the
old-fashioned way they want to earn it
we have hidden a daily double somewhere
in one of these 30 monitors we consider
ourselves to be the rolls-royce of
game shows if you want to test your
intellectual skills
and that's part of the challenge and
part of the great appeal of jeopardy
part of the show's success alex easy
going style he was kind of a cross
between
your best friend and your favorite
teacher people view me as an ordinary
guy so they're friendly towards me
and i've never been involved in any
scandals so the paparazzi have no reason
to pursue me
and besides they would have trouble
keeping up with my
dodge pickup truck i'd run them off the
road alex mostly lived his private life
out of the public eye
and survived more than one health crisis
he suffered a mild heart attack in 2007
and was back to work in a matter of
weeks so when i got this
pain in my chest and in the middle of my
back it caught me
sort of by surprise i didn't think hard
at all just a year before his cancer
diagnosis he let fans know that he was
recovering from brain
surgery i had a slight medical problem
subdural hematoma blood clots on the
brain
caused by a fall i endured about two
months ago
he hosted more than eight thousand
episodes of jeopardy
and modestly refused to take too much
credit i'm good at what i do
and have been for a long time but
i never ever discount
the importance that luck has played in
my career
if i had not been asked to host jeopardy
where would i be today i might be
teaching high school i might be teaching
university who knows not afraid to poke
a little fun at his image
he played himself on sesame street
cheers the nanny
and the golden girls her response to
american hero buried in grant's tomb was
who is cary grant we're part of the
american cultural scene
and it's kind of neat to have people uh
poke fun at us and i like it on hot in
cleveland
he showed off his acting chops as a park
ranger i read your smoke signals
telling me that there were women here in
jeopardy
we caught his playful side during a
visit to the jeopardy set in 1988
tripod we keep these things if you don't
register
them in on the way so we'll take this
away from you thank you very much
i doubt very much if there are many
differences between the real alex trebek
and alex trebek the host of jeopardy
although i do have a wild and crazy
sense of humor that doesn't get a chance
to express itself too often on jeopardy
okay that's another 20 seconds
alex became a dad later in life i don't
have any children of my own yet
but it's not too late believe me he was
50 when he and wife gene became parents
to son matthew
and daughter emily who are now both in
their 20s
and as much as alex will be always
remembered for making us
a whole lot smarter we're grateful to
have welcomed him into our homes
alex was truly family i want the viewers
to like me and over the years they have
demonstrated that they do and
i'm very proud of that